Thomas wirst Du demnächst wieder öfter
bei Fernsehsendung zu sehen sein oder
dabei Raps Turmspringen mitmachen wollen
bisher kam vom Stefan Raab keine
Einladung was auch nicht warum gut ich
bin auf jeden Fall für Meister
Sperenzchen auch gern zu haben und alles
was was ich selbst vertreten kann und
ich sage cool das würde ich noch
mitmachen aber ja wer weiß was noch auf
mich zukommt
es fällt auf dass du deine
Internetpräsenz ziemlich erhöht hast und
wir wollen gerne mal wissen ob das deine
Idee war wir haben natürlich überlegt
weil dann die Plattenfirma was was
zusammen mit der Plattenfirma und was
können wir jetzt noch mehr machen noch
schöner machen und die Leute von der
Plan für immer die haben sehr sehr gute
Leute sehr sehr gute Grafiker auch ähm
und ähm Internet Gestalter
aussetzen habe ich mich
auseinandergesetzt und ja das ist jetzt
quasi was man jetzt im Internet sieht
auch im Stand und den Leuten vertraue
ich da und die machen ja Arbeit sehr gut
die Erneuerung deiner offiziellen
Fanpage hat er ziemlich lange gedauert
also seit Helden gesucht ist da jetzt
nicht mehr so viel passiert
woran lag das jetzt direkt und die neuen
Fotos die darauf zu sehen sind kannst du
dich mit den 100%ig identifizieren wir
haben halt eine Fotosession gemacht und
mich auf ein paar Klamotten auch noch
angezogen gut manchen gefällt es nicht
manchen gefällts das ist halt die
Geschmäcker verschieden zu dem Zeitpunkt
von das eigentlich ganz coole Geschichte
und deshalb habe ich das auch so gemacht
ja